every morning in the boat District of
Kathmandu pilgrimage around this holy
site the stupa it is a daily ritual that
may look ordinary but for Tibetans who
have been living as refugees in Nepal
it's one thing they could do without
fear of getting arrested we managed to
speak to a man who asked us to conceal
his identity he came to Nepal as a
teenager after the first wave of
Tibetans had arrived in 1959 when then
King Mahendra opened its borders to
those fleeing the Chinese occupation of
Tibet
in your Homeland
are you allowed to practice your
religion I'm not able to comment on that
in August 2008 Nepali police detained
760 Tibetans for protesting against a
Crackdown in Tibet by Chinese
authorities in 2019 dozens were also
arrested in the days pleading up to
Chinese president XI jinping's visit to
Nepal since then Chinese ministers have
also visited
a visit by Chinese minister to Kathmandu
would have triggered protests amongst
the Tibetans in the past but these
refugees now live in fear they've become
quiet and inaccessible
rights activists say Chinese officials
have been the subject of protests
because of violations of tibetan's
Rights but the Tibetan Refugee we spoke
to wouldn't even elaborate on why he
left his homeland
the reason that people come here from
Tibet is obvious I can't talk about it
the Nepali
gots repeatedly stated it adheres to a
one China policy
National Human Rights Commission says
freedom of political expression is
outside its mandate I think that is the
political
related questions uh relation between
the China and Nepal what political
situation and what what is the standard
of Government of Nepal but Tibetan
refugees say there is a much more urgent
and pressing concern their children are
going up stateless
you can borrow or beg for money but you
can do that for identity papers
expressions of his Tibetan identity
adorned his home but he worries his
children won't even have a place to call
home
partner below Al Jazeera Kathmandu